ah Utah the perfect place for
snowmobiling and it's where we meet our
next king of carnage Tim Patton theory
is having fun
but in March 2011 Tim's fun was
seriously interrupted as I come up to
the top of the hill I give it a quick
blip of the throttle to sink the rear
end
I step off of the sled and boom I feel
the the slope take off and I'm off to
the races down to the trees
immediately the snow starts to suck you
under so I was swimming hard to the left
trying to get to the other side of these
trees and I'm feeling like if I don't
miss these trees it's not going to be
good I feel the initial impact and then
immediately I'm being pushed hard with
hundreds of pounds of snow
both legs wrapped around the trees and
thought for sure my legs were gonna
break right then we didn't know at that
time how badly ken was hurt or if he was
even dead so what exactly had Tim and
his snowmobile done to trigger the
ice-cold carnage so on the side of the
mountain it's a battle of gravity versus
friction snow builds up in layers you
get a big layer of thick dense snow and
then another layer of thick dense snow
on top but in between the only thing
keeping them together is a little bit of
friction there's this whole layer of
snow that just wants to slip down it's
all ready to go it just needs someone
come along on their snowmobile and
trigger
as soon as Tim adds his weight with the
snowmobile it's too much the friction
isn't enough to keep the snow there and
the whole slab starts to slide down the
mountain but can white fluffy snow do
any damage to it tough dude like to him
that wall of snow is equivalent to about
nine thousand metric tons now that's the
weight of about fourteen blue whales and
it's traveling at somewhere between 40
and 60 kilometers per hour which is
really high speed to ever blue well
coming toppling down on top of you Tim
suffered serious ligament damage to both
knees a small price to pay for escaping
with his life so has this experience
changed Tim's taste for the white stuff
had a three months of rehab on both
knees and I was ready for the next
winter as soon as it started snow and I
was ready to go it hasn't changed me
it's too much fun to think about oh it's
too dangerous we like getting far out
and we're looking for a good time every
time we go out